الى افغانستان حيث نقل مراسل الجزيره هناك
عن مصدر املي ان 10 اشخاص قتلوا واصيب
ثمانيه في تفجيرنا عند المدخل الرئيسي
للمطار العسكري وسط العاصمه كابول
ومن كابول ينضم الى الان مراسل الجزيره
ناصر شديد ناصر يعني لم نسمع بانفجارات
قرب المطار منذ ربما سيطرت حكومه طالبان
على الحكم ما الذي جرى بتحديد اليوم
الاول لها هذا التفكير همم كان عبر
انتحاري يقود دراجه ناريه مفخخه حسب ما
فهمنا من احد المصادر الامنيه همم اقترب
من مكان ال- همم التفتيش الذاتي للمواطنين
الذين
اوعا العاملين الموظفين الامنيين الذين
يريدون الدخول الى مطار قابل هناك العسكري
هناك ثلاث نقاط تفتيش في احد هذه
المكان الامني كان هناك طابور لهؤلاء
فاستغل هذا المكان الذي فيه عدد كبير في
ساعات الصباح الباكره وفجر نفسه عند هذه
النقطه
وطبعا قتل 10 اشخاص بالاضافه الى اصابه
همم ثمانيه حسب مصدر امني هناك اربعه من
القتلهم من
الامنيه وهناك ايضا همم خمسه من المصابين
يتبعون لموظفين يعملون داخل المطار
العسكري هذا المطار قريب جدا تقريبا 400
متر من وزاره الداخليه التي تعرضت قبل
ثلاثه اشهر ايضا الى هجوم لربما كان
انتحاريا داخل مسجد وزاره الداخليه همم
طبعا هذا الامر ليس منفصلا عن احداث سابقه
قبل اسبوع كان هناك ثلاثه استهدافات كهجوم
همم عبوات ناسفه وايضا هجوم باسلحه
اوتوماتيكيه في ثلاث مناطق شماليه تخار
بدخن بالاضافه الى ولايه بنشير همم حتى
هذا الوقت همم يعني عبد الصمد لم تعلن اي
جهه مسؤوليه عن هذا الهجوم بعد ثلاث ساعات
ونصف من هذا الاستهداف لكن اصابع الاتهام
هذا التفجير بكونه انتحاريا لربما تقف
خلفه همم تنظيم الدوله يقف خلفه تنظيم
الدوله فحتى هذا الوقت لا يوجد اي اعلان
لكن هذه هي التوقعات وهناك تجديد امني
هناك اغلاق للمنطقه التي حصل فيها التفجير
منعنا نحن كجزيره من
الاقتراب من ذاك المكان ومنع ايضا
الصحفينا من التقاط اي صوره همم داخل تلك
المناطق شكرا